hi I'm Andrea Kalas at the British Film
Institute for those of you who are
wirelessly multitasking that's wwf/e or
UK for those of you who don't know the
British Film Institute you know I like
to say we've been providing access to
heritage moving images since 1938 that's
before I worked there I'm still working
even at UCLA in Virginia and we do an
enormous range of activities that the
BFI if you're not familiar with it we
have theaters on the south bank we have
a DVD label we have a publishing arm
that does books and a magazine called
sight and sound you may be familiar with
we have the archive which our marketing
department is currently arguing is the
largest in the world and I don't really
try to dissuade them from that view and
we have incredible film festival so
London Film Festival which you probably
heard of and we really said gay and
lesbian Film Festival which started you
know in the mid 80s sort of way ahead of
a lot of people so it's a fantastic
organization with lots of different
things going on all the time in the sort
of educational online space what a
really incredible resource is screen
online which is screen online org dot
uk'
and it's really become a definitive
resource for people looking for
information about British film and
television we've just begun a fantastic
project which is been funded by JISC
which Marie referred to earlier which is
the higher education funding body to
allow resources to be available online
and the project that we're starting is
called the voices moving images in the
public sphere and the project really is
about having a curatorial viewpoint
towards these Moving Image resources to
give them a way of actually having
context and narrative some of the words
I've heard today to really display them
so there be themes having to do with
political social economic history
in the 20th century in britain and the
idea is that moving images have played a
key role in those kinds of histories and
that different moving images often give
a different viewpoint and our plan is to
actually juxtapose those different
moving images online and give people a
chance to actually look at the different
ways a particular event or idea was
expressed through moving images we're
really excited about this project and
it's really a tribute to JISC as well
because it's 600 hours so it's not a
large quantity of material where we are
emphasizing quality in a lot of ways
quality through the interpretation
through our curatorial staff they've
been working on a lot of the work as
well as quality of the actual archival
image they're very supportive of efforts
that take into account preservation as
well as access so really it's drilled
with that but that's not one I'm going
to talk about I'm actually going to talk
about just over here a little bit about
co-production that we've done with the
BBC and we did we've actually come
together with something that I think is
really exciting and I think to sort of
start it off I'll just show a little
clip
this is Bradford on Thursday the 10th of
April 1902 filmed from the front of a
tram this film was made by the early
filmmakers say Garr Mitchell and James
Kenyon it's just one of hundreds of
their films recently discovered in a
cellar in Blackburn Lancashire the films
were nearly lost forever
they'd taken to the world of the real
Edwardian 'he's in a way our generation
has never seen before
we will find out who these people were
and what their lives were like
as a result of the popularity of the
Mitchell and Kenyon program the BBC now
regularly co-produced with the British
Film Institute we've done another
program called the open road which I'll
talk about a little later as well and
we're working right now on production
co-production about the Dalai Lama based
very much on footage that we have in the
collection and the idea of the
co-production really allows us to work
together to use the best efforts of both
the archive as well as the BBC together
so just a little bit about Mitchell and
Kenyon in that footage that you saw
because it is really compelling Mitchell
and Kenyon were the last names of two
portrait photographers that were based
in Blackburn in the north of England and
they saw an opportunity before moving
images really had a wide distribution
from any kind of studio setting or
company they were novelties and they
were novelties for people to go and see
at carnivals and in city halls and so
they took their cameras out where there
would be lots of people which meant
coming out of factory gates or along
city streets and just filmed them with
big signs saying come and see yourself
later at the carnival or that weather
town house and what they did actually
which was fantastic was actually record
all these amazing faces from that time
period so that's why they're it's
extraordinary material the archive
worked closely the BFI worked closely
with the University of Sheffield and
actually interpreting and cataloging
these films as well and that's an
important connection for education as
well is that we did work with them to
actually build this information about
the film's because it wasn't immediately
available from just a roll of film and I
can so this is one of the kinds of
materials that Pete our colleagues at
the University of Sheffield found to
actually show where these materials were
shown to give them some provenance in
some context so this
business opportunity for this novelty as
I said turned into this amazing social
weapon and they were really ordinary
people in everyday situations and this
is um this slide here it's just from
Morcom a seaside resort in in England
and it was all the north of England and
Scotland in some of Ireland that some of
these materials were shot there were
over 800 nonfiction titles for truth
between 1900 and 1913 and original
negatives for those archivists recovered
and otherwise in the audience from this
from this time period are incredibly
rare prints are what survived most at
the time so this gave us this amazingly
beautiful kind of condition and quality
of the image from this period as well
they would film at anything they thought
people would pay to see but by filming
at factory gates as in this film they
will be guaranteed big audiences the
people they filmed will be curious
enough to pay to see themselves on
screen
they were shown in tents at fairgrounds
and in musicals all over the northwest
and these local films were the most
popular item on the bill
but these amazing films only came to
light in 1994 by accident
build the refitting a shot when they
discovered three metal churns at a cold
basement full of old film they were
nearly toun away but fortunately they
hand him over to local film historian
Peter worden instead he realized
immediately that this was a forgotten
treasure of Mitchell in Kenyan films he
stole them carefully before donating the
fine to the nation the British Film
Institute took charge of historic
collection and painstakingly restored it
it took three years but now the results
are amazing a hundred year old films
with hardly a scratch many as clear as
the day they are shot
covered three metal churns at a cold
basement full of old film they were
nearly thrown away but fortunately they
hand him over to local film historian
Peter worden instead he realized
immediately that this was a forgotten
treasure of Mitchell and Kenyon films he
stole them carefully before donating the
fine to the nation the British Film
Institute took charge of historic
collection and painstakingly restored it
it took three years but now the results
are amazing a hundred-year-old filled
with hardly a scratch many is clear the
day they are shot so that's a clip just
to give more of the footage but also
just to show you how the BBC program
absolutely relied on a lot of the
research that the BFI and the University
of Sheffield had done to actually create
the information about the program and we
did you know a very wide release of the
programs there was theatrical lease
across the country academic conferences
you know that Mitchell and Kenyon was
both canon Cheney changing in the sort
of film studies but it was also a
household world around the country close
adventurous journey took him past a
hundred and fifty places from
mountaintops to bustling cities
along the way he filmed his faces of
grownups and children belong to a bygone
era
that was from the open road which was a
second project that we did with BBC
co-production call in this their lost
world series and here's just an example
some of the research that we did about
the open road about how the information
about cars and travel and amateur
footage was all happening about 1926
when these films were being made and
touring the British countryside was
being sold in a lot of ways and Claude
friese-greene son of William
friese-greene the British pioneer was
really behind this whole process to do
this kind of color process and it was a
based on a kinemacolor process and it
was so popular that it sort of filled
theatres as large as some IMAX theaters
are now this one was called the Scala
and Charlotte Street in London and this
is a picture of Claude with his camera
on a boat
colored positive was shown at a fast
speed indeed a speed faster than most
projectors were running at the time the
images combined to the eye in the brain
to the mechanics the brain really to
create the illusion of a natural full
colored world amazing really and claude
said that um this film would work in any
cinema providing that cinema had a
projector that could run at a faster
than usual speed because that for Claude
was of a powerful pitch sales pitch for
his color process however it was a
tricky process and for audiences at the
time within the end result might have
looked rather like this thrust nowadays
is not that easy to watch but with
modern-day printing technology the
British Film Institute who carefully
preserved installed Claude archive has
succeed in making this much more
watchable version of a powerful pitch
sales pitch for his color process
however it was a tricky process and for
audiences at the time we think the end
result might have looked rather like
this for us nowadays is not that easy to
watch but with modern-day printing
technology the British Film Institute
who carefully preserved and stored Claus
archive has succeed in making this much
more watchable version I'm just going to
show you one final clip of the
restoration that we did so this is the
and so again I think you know the
research that the producer Emma Hindley
of these programmes who was fantastic
did she absolutely paid attention to the
kind of accuracy and historical research
we've done both with the technology and
the surrounding contextual history and
it gave us gives us a chance to to
showcase this work that we do spend a
lot of time on restoring and because
Claude had sort of red and green palette
he liked redheads or gingers as we go
here's some more information about the
open road and I have to just end quickly
with a shot from our media tech on the
south bank if you're in London you must
come by we've about 400 hours of
archived footage available there which
is another way we're giving access to
the world thanks very much